as i mentioned before the break one of
the biggest beneficiaries of the last 48
to 72 hours of the news cycle being on
the derrick chauvin case has been
republican congressman matt gates
who is in full full damage control mode
my he should be in resignation mode not
damage control mode
and uh i i believe that the attention is
going to get back to matt gates there's
a very
interesting daily beast article uh which
points out that quote
his latest campaign finance report
reflects a public relations scramble
that began even before he acknowledged
being the focus of a federal
investigation
we now are learning that matt gates knew
much earlier that he was the focus of
this investigation and that he was
already working
on his public relations campaign the
filing which covers the three months
between january and march
writes the daily beast shows that gates
has incurred unprecedented fundraising
expenses during a typically quiet
period in that time gates dropped six
figures on a direct mail blitz
shelling out more for fundraising
services than he did in all of 2020. now
understand the cycle
one of my criticisms of the status quo
of the house of representatives and
two-year terms is that with two-year
terms
you basically get elected you get six
months
and then you start campaigning again
matt gates
is doing the fundraising during that
six-month period where you were
typically not campaigning it's basically
a year and a half of campaigning not two
matt gates is starting right away and it
tells us
quite a bit about the panic that he is
likely feeling as a result of these
investigations
the article goes on to say gates also
paid five thousand dollars
in strategic consulting fees to
notorious political operative
roger stone and he gave money to a
number of republican florida state
lawmakers that he has never supported
before
what it appears he's trying to do there
and again we're left to read into the
actions of a madman
it seems he's trying to curry favor with
some of these fellow florida republicans
so that they will not abandon him and
hopefully will speak out in his support
if and when it gets really really ugly
for him which could be any time
the daily beast writes that the report
also indicates gates
may be increasingly isolated he's
received no contributions from his
republican
colleagues more than anything the filing
reflects a concerted effort
to bolster support ahead of the creeping
shadow of the investigation gates has
spent roughly 170k
on direct mail this year 160 000 of it
all on one day march 31st
i think that's the day after i i know i
was on
our i was on our break that day that
must be the day after
the bizarre interview with tucker
carlson the previous day the new york
times broke the news that the justice
department was looking into whether he
had sex with a 17 year old and paid for
her travel
which possibly violates federal sex
trafficking
laws gates has also invested in
fundraising paying nevada-based redrock
strategies
nearly 160k for fundraising consulting
that's more than he spent on fundraising
services
in 2019 and 2020 combined
that is stunning last week politico
reported gates spent six figures on tv
ads punching back against the
accusations
30 second spots slated to run in his
home district in the florida panhandle
and on national cable networks
asking supporters to quote fight back
against a quote multi-week fake news
cycle targeting cnn there is one expense
in particular raising eyebrows a five
thousand dollar strategic political
consulting fee to drake
ventures that's the company belonging to
roger stone
friday the department of justice sued
stone and his wife saying they owe
millions of dollars in unpaid taxes
and are using that very same drake
ventures
to shelter more than one million dollars
isn't that unbelievable look at look at
how
the tentacles of gates are spreading
into so many different things so there's
the investigation into
gates which we already talked about and
then now in light of that it's sort of
weird that gates was the lone no vote on
some
sex trafficking bill a couple of years
ago or whatever okay that's weird and
we're starting to see that in a new
light
then we learn about gates's alleged
involvement
in a shill candidate scheme in a
different district
in the state of florida we had a report
on that i believe it was earlier mid
last week now we find out
that gates paid a consulting fee to
roger stone's company
and it is the very same company that now
allegedly is a way for roger stone and
his wife
to shelter more than a million dollars
and
uh avoid paying taxes it's so
tied in with all of this stuff and in a
sense i don't feel bad for him
but gates may end up being another sort
of victim
of the trump grift the way that the
trump grift works
is trump loves you loves you loves you
for as long as you
are saying good things about him and for
as long as you are useful to him and
trump will introduce you to all sorts of
different people who knows how matt
gates ended up
sort of entangled with roger stone in
the first place my instinct is that it
has something to do with donald trump
as soon as you were no longer useful to
trump or as soon as you were potentially
a problem due to your own
issues that you were having from a
public relations standpoint trump is
gone
and uh indeed the reports are that matt
gates has been trying to meet with trump
uh matt gates has been claiming that he
has donald trump support although it's
not
completely clear that that's the case
and uh it it is another
in at least partially i'm not saying
gates did the stuff if if gates did the
stuff he's accused of doing he didn't do
it because of donald trump
but he is another one of these guys who
got sort of lulled into trump's circle
as a brown-nosing
sycophant and then dropped like a bad
habit as soon as he was no longer useful
one other piece of this very extensive
daily beast article about what's going
on with matt gates
quote the report also suggests gates has
few friends in washington
while gates swore off donations from
corporate packs he kept the door open to
donations from candidate committees
but he has so far reported no financial
support in 2021 from friends in congress
like jim jordan and steve scalise
both of whom donated back in 2020 while
gates made same-day 4 000 donations to
mike lee and rand paul
gates did not give money to any house
colleagues
he did send out a thousand a few five
one thousand dollar donations to five
republican florida senators
and had not donated to their campaigns
previously
so uh i would expect
that the media attention will go back to
matt gates at some point relatively
soon at some point relatively soon i
would imagine we will know whether there
will be charges filed as a result of
what appear to be multiple
investigations into
matt gates uh but certainly gates must
be thrilled
that for the last two to three days the
focus has been not on him but rather
on derek chovin we'll get back to him no
question about it